about 116 million people spent part of
the day shopping on Black Friday many of
them in malls and big box stores while
you might still find crowds in your
local mall today many people are
expected to spend their money at small
businesses it's what's known as Small
Business Saturday and as Carter Evans
reports the plan backed by American
Express to support local businesses back
in 2010 continues to pay off there are
no doorbuster deals atlandis labyrinth
toy shop in Los Angeles but Small
Business Saturday means a big boost in
sales we have a really great community
that supports us and we support them
Deveney wolfish opened a single store in
2009 and has since expanded to 3 she
believes donating to schools and
connecting with customers is more
important than offering deep discounts
we make sure that they pick the right
product for the right child well some
shoppers prefer to brave the mall
madness John Gordon and his son Kenya
want to support a store that provides a
unique experience
it just feels special like you feel that
you know you don't feel like you're
going to a big nameless faceless place
according to the National Retail
Federation 71 million people say they'll
shop today and 76 percent of those plan
to spend at small businesses Darrell
halter is one of the owners at LA's
oldest independent bookstore and he's
not offering deep discounts to get
customers in he doesn't need to do you
have customers who shop here
specifically because they want to keep
your store life yes
we're offering something that's a little
bit different and something that has
roots in the neighborhood the campaign
to help small businesses compete with
the big guys appears to be working in
2016 an estimated 112 million shoppers
bought on Small Business Saturday a 13
percent increase from the year before
but it's so much easier just a point and
click but you don't get that one-on-one
person-to-person interaction for CBS
this morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles know what I love about small
businesses small selection yes and I
like the excuse of being able to go
shopping with a good conscience which is
what I will do today Thank You Carter
Evan